sólo unos minutos después de llegar a la
escena de las llamas estos bomberos
alemanes comenzaron a trabajar duro
equipados con bolsas llenas de agua
puntana los puntos calientes
extinguiendo el fuego antes de que se
extienda sin embargo para estos
operarios los bosques del suroeste de
francia son un campo de batalla
desconocido the landscape el paisaje las
plantas que crecen aquí los combustibles
que hay son diferentes y las superficies
también
quitan la vegetación circundante a mano
para que nada se encienda es una tarea
ardua pero necesaria la colaboración no
es perfecta todavía pero he dicho que
mientras no tenga un papel francés que
diga que está permitido no los uso aquí
y si un bombero francés se une al equipo
la barrera del idioma puede dificultar
el trabajo de todo lo que hay o técnico
como una rivas con fondos sombrillas o
como son gp de tope prius aiko basten y
los demás bomberos alemanes destacados
aquí se ofrecieron como voluntarios para
luchar contra las llamas para ellos es
un acto esencial
stofile
y unos 60 bomberos alemanes están
turnando para trabajar en el incendio
pronto se les unirán más de 300 de otros
países europeos